turns throws it back to the corner flurry Knocks
The Bouncing Puck up against the sideboard steel
out to the line for Peli pavelski moves in cut
off tried to Center flurry goes down and the
loose plck Swept Away by mermis on the heels
of his skates then pavi gets in on the mix
throws missing wider the N before D had to take
the penalty so Stars power play first look com
remember this power play was such a huge part
of their win in the playoffs and they score
just 6 seconds into the power play Joel pavelski
beats Mark Andre flurry and the wild down one 57
seconds into the game on the Year this top unit
with just three but they win the first battle
that's the faceof and the wild don't get out high
enough fast enough and that allows the three at
the top to just play catch until Aenon gets a
shot at this one throws it towards the net it
gets through Mark Andre flurry just sits there
on a t for pavi and he just recovered by danov
who sent it cross ice now danov back to the line
shot by list is loose out front flurry down got
a pat on it flurry deflex it into the corner
Johansen sends it across for ler he mishandles
it off the boards faxa with a shot he scores and
the short-handed goal puts Dallas in front two z
boy this is just miscommunication it's all so
close from one end to the back of your net in
the other end but capriso just lets this go not
not thinking about what was on the backside there
and that put and the wild now staring at a twoo
deficit here at home to ha to Felino who relays
it down and into the Dallas Zone tinger there
to play it for the Stars loose Puck out front D
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] scores
well Evon getting rewarded after power play he
just puts a four checking group out there dur
does a good job and lanquist just throws this
one to the slot no chance Robertson's going to
pick that one up on his feet good position from
D and the wild cut the Dallas lead to two to
one fourth this season for du but Dallas now
answers at the other end and it's 31 Stars it
takes them almost no time to answer the new
goal Matt Duane who's been redot this road
trip for Dallas has the stars in front 3-1 yeah
now this time it's Marchman who gets in on the
four check just wins the battle on fav that
creates the lose Puck and he's able to even
pick this one up and through three sticks out
front Rossi just off the bench as duain slid it
ahead for San the end of the corner to go
Spurgeon got it up the boards intercepted
out front by broin he leads the charge to
Rossi ahead now to lataria shot off the
throw he scores later goes over the shoulder of
uttinger his second goal with the Wild and it's
32 well it's The Scouting Report odd man
Rush ler turns on the Jets Harley can't
catch up to him that it's just a perfectly
placed shot it's the release too he doesn't
load this one up it's a quick little snap
oer isn't set wait waiting for ler to get
his shot dialed so he can read it doesn't
get the opportunity quick release well
placed with the top five scorers on that team
aside from those five the next closest guy was
20 points behind like it was an effective
power play centering pass and they score
Johnston with the one-time from the slot and a
pretty passing play with just 10 seconds left
in the power play has Dallas in front by two one
more time two to the wild this one goes down low
quick little touch from duch shaine boy that's
a quick passing play crisp caught in between B
Goan is a little bit Johnson just enough room
to be able to fire this one off from the slot
and it's the positioning there tried to feed
it across and it's another low Breakaway this
one for Johnston moving in against furry
pad save by flurry what a stop by the
Minnesota golender game saer for for Minnesota
stopping Johnston to keep Minnesota within
two back up high for lanquist duim got a stick on
it not enough to clear the Zone Sagen pressured
by ler Johnston back to the line a shot rebound
Johnston and they score a third power play goal
for Dallas in this game this time it's dadonov
on the rebound and it's 52 Stars this second
power play unit for Dallas now has three goals
in the last two games Johnson redirects the first
rebound off Al Luna shot to the net and then
donov just finishes it off as Middleton gives
him a shot watch little cross check that puts
it on him down but he's got ins power play now
for Minnesota Baldi gives it to Rossi back
to Baldi up high capriso across zuk carella
[Music]
scores well power play Cashes in for the wild
again they're finding ways to stay in this game
it's zuk Carell what makes the plays that he
doesn't take long like it's it's on and off
the stick in a hurry you've got the moving screen
from Johansson and if he holds on to that puck any
longer pavelski to the line
henan henan Looks Robertson forced outside
by Spurgeon Ben back to henan wies fires
that goes wide flurry knocked down and they
score on the rebound Robertson in to pounce
on the loose Puck and with flurry down and
out of position Robertson does not miss it's
6-3 Dallas they'd like to get going and
get done it's get the power play going
they've done that tonight get Robertson
on the board on the power play they do
that now talked about losing or winning
some of these battles around Mark Andre
flurry there's four guys inside the paint and
somehow Robertson comes in back to Robertson
hence Robertson forced to the outside gives it to
henan Robertson a long shot he scores
a fifth power play goal for the Stars
second for Robertson and it's 7 to
three three up top and just isolating
the forwards looking to find the lane
and this one does get through Mark Andre
flurry one time timer not a really heavy shot
not redirected potentially a late moving screen
no you're absolutely right and one of the
great things about the NHL is there's a lot
of games and if you have a bad one there's
a good chance you've got one the next day
or two another lone Breakaway and they score a
short-handed goal for Johnston it's the fourth
lone Breakaway Dallas has had on Mark Andre
flurry tonight Dallas has scored on second
shorty of the game for [Music] Dallas brings
their special teams total to seven on the
night but Dallas and some time for some heavy
thought on the way things have gone here the
last couple games as Dallas comes into St Paul
and delivers a whooping on the wild 83 the final